よろしくお願いします
えっと まあまあ 早速できるだけ今日も早く飛ばしていきますので
ブッダの正しい食生活というテーマにはしています
智慧の完成と食の安全ということで
まあ世の中では食に対してどのように考えているのかというところはね
一応講演の説明文書を通して発表されてますからね
その内容について喋ると
私何喋るかわからなくなっちゃいますからね
で そこは省略します  それからね
まあみんなこのかなり興味あるテーマなんですからね
まあお釈迦様の智慧って何を食べればね
より美しく より長く 長くね
1万年でもね 生きてられるのとかね
で 考えている可能性もないわけじゃないんですけど
まあ一応仏教は真理を語る世界ですから
食に対して真理 これどうやって動かすんですかね
あ 動いた まずタイトルとして
この一つは何？というね
なんかびっくりしますね
一つは何っていうのはね
パーリ語でエーカナーマキンというね
一と言えるのは何？という質問なんです
一とは何？答えはサッエーサッターアーハラッティティカー
一切の生命は 仏教用語で滋養素というふうに訳されています
いわゆる食ですね によって成り立っているんだと
仏教でいう一はそれなんです
これはエピソードがございまして
このソーバーカという名前のね
沙弥がいて この子供なんですね
すごくちっちゃな子供で
お釈迦様がまあこれあれ
何でしたっかね 親に捨てられたちっちゃな子供でね
お釈迦様はまあ見つけて連れて行ったんです
すごくいい子供でね まあそれから出家されて
まあすぐたちまちまあ修行して悟りに達したんですよ
まだ小さな子供で で ある日
その子供の沙弥とね お釈迦様が質問したんですね
君 一って何ですかと ただ
答えはこのソーバーカ沙弥の阿羅漢ですけどね
この阿羅漢の答えなんですね
だからなんか私も昨日これ考えたらね
もうびっくりしたんですね
で これは誰にも答えられない質問なんですね
一って何ですか？っていうね
そこでこの子供がね 子供と言っていいかどうかよくわかりませんだけど
当時ではお釈迦様の前では７歳 ８
歳ぐらいの子供ですから
でしたからね で だからお釈迦様がこの生きること
生きる 生きるということはどういうことかとかね
意味があるのかないのかとかね
そういうことだけ仏教のテーマですからね
だから膨大な仏教経典とか
あれこれあるんですけど
結局はもうすべて生命とは何ですかっていうところの分析で終わってるんです
アビダンマテキストもね
もう膨大大量で七つもありまして
注釈書なんか見るともうちょっと逃げたくなるぐらいの量なんですけど
こんなたくさんなっても
結局はこの生命とは何かというね
ことについて語ってるんでしょ
生きることについて そこでいきなり一度なんですかと聞いたところでびっくり
私もよくびっくりするのは
この子供が自分なりにこのすごいことを発見したことなんですね
瞑想して智慧があることも確かでしょうし
まあ智慧があると言ったっても
生命ってなんたるものやと
どんな構成でしょうかと
子供はいくら智慧があったってもね
そういうところを考えて
そんな結論に達するっていうことは難しいと思いますよ
そこで達した結論は 生命っていうのはいつでも何かエネルギーをスーッと供給して
スーッとエネルギーをあげないと成り立たない
壊れちゃうんです それを仏教用語で滋養想と呼ぶんですね
これをパーリ語でアーハラっていうんですね
アーハラっていうのは
もうもう普通のパーリ辞書を引いてみれば
もう食べるものという意味なんですよ
で 日本語で食べるっていうのは
まあ食べる 口に入れることですからね
噛むことでしょうし パーリ語のアーハラのサンスクリット語のアーハラの意味っていうのは
やっぱり自分の方向へ運ぶという動詞なんですね
噛むという意味ではないんです
自分の方向へ運ぶことをアーハラって言うんですね
そういうわけで 食べ物にも使う食べ物っていうのは
どうしても自分の方向へ行くものだから
中に行くものだからね
ですから 生命体はスーッと何かエネルギーをスーッと取り入れていないと
命は成り立たないんですね
結構やばいんですよ スーッとエネルギーを供給しなくちゃいけない
だから全体的に生命を見ると
ああ これ滋養想によって支えられてるんだわと
みんなこれたった一つだと
だから一度これであると
この子供が決めたこと
すごいでしょう で 注釈書でびっくりしているのはね
普通の子供に一は二は何？と聞いたらね
まあ一はこれ 二はこれやと言うでしょうとかね
でもお釈迦様はそういうそういう子供遊びはしませんね
だから ちゃんと大事な存在について質問するんですね
で 結構子供とはそういう遊び
結構ではなくて いくつかありましてね
あるまた女の子にね で
説法会に来るんですね
遅くなって この子来るまでお釈迦様待っていたんですよ
説法しないでみんな待ってるんです
お釈迦様は気にしないで
この小さな貧しい家の子供なんですね
女の子が来るまで待っていて
遅くなってもやっと来ると
君どこから来る？質問したら知りませんねと答えた
お釈迦様知りません ではどこへ行く？これから
それも知りません 本当に知らないの？知ってます
というやりとりなんです
それで一般のお年寄りの方々
このメスかいみたいなカーストのね
女の子がね よくも偉大なる釈迦様に対してそんな失礼なことをと怒ったんですよ
怒ったらお釈迦様はまあちょっと待ってくださいと
どこから来るのかと聞いたら
なんで知らないと言ったんですかね
君はと だって女の子 だってお釈迦様はアホな質問しないでしょうしと
無知な質問なさらないでしょうにと
お釈迦様は恐らく私に聞いたのは
私はどこからこの世で生まれたのかいってことでしょうと
それ知りませんだから知りませんと答えたんだと
そうしたらお釈迦様はその通りだと
私は俗世間でね あなたどんな家から来たんですかと聞いていたわけじゃないんだと
そういうことで お釈迦様の質問というのは結構怖い質問にもなる場合あります
で まあこの場合も まあまあ子供相手になってくると
そういうなぞなぞ遊びになりますけどね
それで子供がそうパーカラカンはいいんだけど
それでその そのソーパークの長老の言葉から
我々にはものすごい真理を
勉強することはできますよ
一とは一切の生命が食によって命を支えられているんですね
だから食なければ命もないんです
すごいことなんです で
生命あるいは存在っていうことはね
何かしらのエネルギーを続けて与えないと生命は成り立たないんです
なんかスーッと与えないといけないんですよ
そのエネルギーは仏教用語でアーハラです
食べ物もアーハラですが
それだけではありません
で この命をずっと支えられているエネルギーにアーハラというんです
食と言うんですね 電気が流れないと電気製品は機能しないように
生命も滋養素によって生きるんです
だからどんな立派な電気機械買ってもね
それコンセントからスーッと電気が流れてないと機能しないでしょ
電気がストップになったらすぐ止まるんです
だから これと同じなんですね
まあ世の中はまあどちらにしたってもそういう法則なんですね
車が走っていると言ったっても
ずっと燃料が燃えて もうエネルギーにしてあげないと
あの あの車が車輪などなど回らないでしょ
たとえ電気自動車にしたっても
モーターにずっと電気が行っていかないと
それでなんか坂道ではまあブレーキ緩んだら自動的に行くんじゃないかと思うでしょ
あれも違いますよ あれもエネルギーなきゃ動かないんです
坂道でブレーキをかけていた車のブレーキを外したら車が動くんですね
それは当然地球のエネルギーでしょ
だから地球はスーッと引っ張ってるんだから
もう行けるところまで行ってどこかにぶつかっちゃうんですね
だから地球は自転しているでしょ
公転しているでしょ だからスーッと互いあのエネルギーのやりとりなければ
太陽と地球の これは止まりますよ
ですから どこを見ても世の中っていうのはエネルギーでできてあって
エネルギーというものは
はい 一旦上げてはい終わりということじゃないんですよ
これ一回きりにしましょうということはできないんです
ずっと与えて与えてあげなくちゃいけない
いくら与えたっても エネルギーは瞬間で消えちゃうんですね
エネルギー消えるっていうことはおかしいんだけど
その機能 ファンクションに応じて別なものになってしまいます
だから 何と言いますかね
ガソリンとかはね ガソリンである時は
まあそれでエネルギーで
そこを燃やしたら まあ車を回してくれて
それから別な品物に変わっちゃう
だから別なエネルギーに変わるんですね
そうすると別な働きできますけど
この働きはまたできません
戻れません そういうふうに物質的な世界を見ても
あれは一方方向へエネルギーが変わって変わって変わって変わっていくんですね
これが生命は特別ではないんです
私たちの命ということも
ずっとコンセントに挿しておかないと
外した瞬間で死んでしまって壊れちゃうんです
このような このなんか難しいんですね
命は支えているエネルギーは何でしょうかと
誰の力によって？これは無限にこの力がないとダメでしょ
例えば人が まあ私みたいなね
67歳まで生きていたらそろそろ8になりますけどね
スーッとエネルギーがね
入りっぱなしでしょ 何にストップで停電もなく
すごいエネルギー量なんですよ
もし 1 秒でもエネルギーが止めたら終わり
だからできるだけ電気の電気と電気器具と比較して考えてください
皆様のね 掃除機なんかはね
何年も使えますね まあだから新しいものが出ると何か悔しいしね
古いものは捨てられないし
まだまだもう本当に仕事をしているしね
まあとは言っても 掃除機はね
コンセントに挿してないと動かないんですね
スイッチというものあるでしょ
あれ スイッチを押したということは
つなげたか切ったかでしょ
つなげて電気流れると
まあ掃除機が元気でグーグーと音を立てながら回ってるんですね
エネルギーがストップした途端
ストップ ただの品物で物体で何の役にも立ちません
では動かない掃除機で何か役に立つことはある？何もないでしょ
だから掃除機はダイソンで 6万
8万ぐらいでね  あれぐらい高いんですかね
あんなのは もうゴミ取れるんですかどうかよくわかりませんだけどね
もう試したくはないんですね
だから考えれば まあとにかく
あんな代物はね 動かないならばえらい迷惑なんですよ
それで動く 動いてもらうためにはずっと電気エネルギーが必要なんです
そういうわけで 私たちの体もダイソンの掃除機みたいなものやと思ったらどうですかね
それよりは役に立ちませんと
値段も高いし 体の値段すごい高いでしょう
1年体を維持するためにどれぐらい金かかることでしょうかね
こんなお金かかって体維持したって何かやってますかね
我々は なんか大事なこととかね
そういうことで このもうちょっと科学的に考えてみましょうね
命っていうのはそういう不思議なものなんです
スーッとエネルギーを与えてあげないと壊れてしまうもので
では このエネルギーは何なのかという問題が出てくるんですね
で なんとなく何かエネルギーが与えているんだということは
だいたいみんななんとなく感じていることなんですよ
だから日本では生かされているという言葉を使っているでしょうね
だから なんとなくかすかに
もうはっきりはないんですよ
なんか微妙に感じているだけ
どんな人間もそういうことなんですね
だから まあ中東の方になってくるとね
なんとなく自分で生きるよりは
なんか運命みたいなもんやと
この人生はと 厳しい環境で生きてるでしょう
だからそちらが偉大なるパワーが外にあると
外にある偉大なるパワーによって生かされていると思っているし
日本でも同じ意味なんですけど
まあそれは別に何かとまだ調べませんね
ただ生かされている 誰が誰でしょうかときたら
ようわからない 天道様でしょうとかね
まあなんとか言うんですね
はい それで あの 何 このエネルギーについては一応微妙に気づいていることなんですね
誰でも はい そういうことで
正しい生活ってなんで食生活って何ですかね
生命に生きるために 輪廻転生するために
滋養は欠かせない だからこの滋養素というエネルギーが
スーッともう流してあげないと
生きていられません 我々は生きているんですね
ということは 相当エネルギーが流れているはずなんです
体に 生きているだけじゃなくて
輪廻転生までしちゃうんですね
ということは ものすごい想像できないほどのエネルギーがあって
そのエネルギーでによって生かされていることになるんです
食っていうのはそういうものなんですね
生命とは結局は何ですかね
早老病死なんです あれほどエネルギーを使って
何やってますかね ただ老いて病気になってくたびれて死ぬだけでしょう
何か偉いことやっちゃった？何もない
何やってもちょっと 1年
2年ぐらい経ってみたら
なんであんな時はあんなアホなことをやったのかいっていうことでしょ
本当に恥ずかしいけど
よく自慢する人間がこの世の中でいるんですよ
我こそあれやこれやと言いながらね
私こそこの国を何て言ったっけ
守ってあげますとかね
勝手にしろよと言いたいんだけど
ろくなことないでしょ
えらい人々が現れて こんなことやって
こんなことやったって言うんだけど
結局は別にどうたことはないんですね
本当に頑張っている方々は
後の世代の人々は褒め称えるのは構わないんだけど
今はそうじゃなくて 自分で言うんですね
私は偉いと そう言うんだったら
もうもう生ゴミですね
人間っていうのは で 結局は生命のことだから
人間だけではなくて 生命があの
ものすごいエネルギーを浪費して
浪費じゃなくてあの使って生きているんです
で 我々はね 困っているのはこの電力とかね
日本のエネルギー問題はどうしようかとかね
ですから まあもう 5 キロ単位でもう間隔で原発でも作っちゃえばいいんじゃないですかね
まあそれぐらいエネルギー欲しければ
で そんなのは大したエネルギーじゃないんですよ
電気エネルギーとかね
化石燃料エネルギーとかね
なに大したことできないんですよ
生きているということは
例えば 1 分間でも 65 から 70 間で心臓はドキンドキンとしているでしょう
これで地球は何回回転するぐらいでしたっけね
血管の長さは  30回とかなんとか
まあいろいろみんな遊びで計算していますけどね
それ地球回ってもね それぐらいの長い血管にこれ血液をパンプしていますからね
では人間に作れますかね
それぐらいの力のある機械は作れないんですよ
作ったっても バカでかいものになっちゃうんですね
この手で取れるぐらいの小さな
だから心臓を動かしているエネルギー自体が何じゃないんです
原発にしたっても 寿命は 40年だからね
日本はまあ 50 20年ですよ
寿命は 日本ではまあ 40年
80年  1800年ぐらいの使いたがってますけど
で ボロボロですけど 日本の技術は世界一と言ったらみんな黙るんですね
で まあそう危険なこともやっちゃいますけど
まあなんで私は余計なことを喋っているんですかね
関係ないことですけど
で 言いたいところは このエネルギー比較しましょうってことなんですね
原発のエネルギーはね
生命にはね 決して敵わないんですよ
生きてるっていう このエネルギー
パワーが しかし 生きるっていうことは生老病死なんですね
これぐらいの人間は一度は仮想する
想像することさえもできなかった
生命力 生きる力 ブッダ以外誰も発見してないし
これほどの力を持って何やってますかね？喧嘩するわ
隣の人のことを嫉妬するわ
立派なことね それでどんどん年取っちゃって
病気になって もう四方八方の人間に文句ばっかり言って
これでくたびれ死んじゃうんですね
何も大したことやらないんですよ
だから もし皆様方は今日ね
お釈迦様からこの生命力
正しくしっかりと生命力をもらう方法を学ぼうと思ったら
教えてあげませんよ そんなのは
だって どのように生老病死するのかいという話でしょ
汝にはより苦しめる方法を教えてあげましょうとか
より悩む方法を教えてあげましょう
100万円借金して困っている人に
あのね あなたには 1,000万円借金する方法を教えてあげますと
その人がかっこいいよ
もう100万円を返せ返せと借金取り立てに脅されていますけど
やっぱりこれ1,000万だったらもっといいよと
こんなことを教えられますかね
足の骨が折れて苦しくて泣いてる人に
あのね この足の 1本足1本だけでしょ
これ本当にこの次の足も両手も折ってもらったら最高よと
あの刺激はと あの苦しみはと
これは仏教以外の世界を教えてあげていますから
仏教の仕事じゃないんです
いかにすべなどく苦しめのかと
いかに強く徹底的に苦しむのかと
結構教えていますからね
だから仏教は苦しみをなくせと教えているんだからね
正しい食生活を教えて
無限に輪廻転生して苦しむ方法は仏教では成り立ちません
だから正しい食生活しなさいということは
君はもうもう地獄餓鬼道輪廻輪廻六道輪廻転生しながら苦しめということでしょう
それできないんです 仏教は解脱を推薦するんです
ということで 今日のお話はなかったことにしましょう
これは何しゃべればいいんですかね
私が何か罪を犯すことになります
これ食ったらいい あれ食ったらいいとか言っちゃうと
はい では 他宗教では神様
絶対誰にも理解できない
もう最大のエネルギーを持っている神様と言ってるでしょ
で 研究をしていないんですね
誰も ただ 喉が渇いてあっちこっち彷徨っている時は
どこかで水のあるところに見つかる
ああ なんてありがたいことで
そこでいざまして 神様
もうありがとうございますと
いうふうに感動するだけ
自分が苦労して仕事をして
なんとか食べるものを手に入って
まあ苦労した分は食べるものを美味しく感じるんですね
それでまたいざまして
もう何だらかんだら何だらかんだらと神に感謝するんですね
だからそれはそれで結構なことなんですけど
そこで心理学的に見て見てみると
自分が仕事をしたんだけど
買い物も自分がしたんだけど
まあ何か生かされているという感じがあるわけですよ
うまくいったと 何かうまくいった時はと
だからそこなんですね
そういう方々が感謝するのは
そこは妄想で神という人格を作って
まあ言う しかし仏教は
まあこれはものすごいエネルギーなんですね
問題はそこにどこにあるんですかと
どこから？どんな星団からとかね
なんか日本である新興宗教もありましたね
なんだらかんだら名前いろいろ星の名前ありますからね
そういう信仰しながら
そこからメッセージが来るんだそうとか
よく信じる人々はものすごいいたんですよ
そういうふうにどこかの宇宙にあるんですかね
このエネルギーを 例えば我々も今使っているエネルギーは太陽から出てくるエネルギーでしょ
電気もすべて でも太陽の力ですね
川も太陽の力で流れているし
もう全部太陽の力 まあこけたりする場合は太陽の力ではない
それ地球の力でこけて怪我したりする場合は地球の力で
川が流れるときは太陽の力で
だから喋っている時でも
結局は太陽の力で喋ってるしね
だからそういう風にある場所
この場所やと言えますかね
物理の世界では 地球の働きは太陽の太陽やと言えます
体の場合は 命の場合はね
アーハールは 4つですと
いわゆるエネルギー 4種類ですね
チャッターローメ チャッターローメ
ビッカビ アーハラ ブータナンワ
サッターナン ティティア
サンバディシーナンワ
アヌッガハヤ これ精密に語れるパーリとお釈迦様の言葉だから
もうもうもう訳できないんです
だからいい加減な訳なんです
比丘たちよ 生まれた生命を生かす
生まれる生命を支える
アーハラは 4つですと
そこですでに生まれている生命
これから生まれつつある生命
2つのお釈迦様は分けるんですね
どちらであっても やっぱりエネルギーがないと 4
種類のコードが差してます
例えば今こちらパワーポイントでこの画像を映してるでしょ
これ見てください エネルギーは何種類ですかね
こちら5本なんですね
あ 5本はいらんだけどね
まあなんで5本ですかね 1
つまた差ししましょうか
まあとにかく 素人 私みたいな素人から見れば
まあ 5種類のラインがあって
パソコンにつなげているんですね
だからこのパソコンのデータがこのスクリーンに映る場合は
やっぱり5種類のエネルギーが働いてます
生命は 4つという なんか格好悪いね
もうちょっと 生命の場合はな
1万ぐらいのエネルギーがあった方が良かったんじゃないかなとかね
まあそれはないんで 自然法則では
このラインが増えると
技術下手っていうことなんです
基本的にはエネルギーはそんな複雑ではありません
だから生命だけ 4種類のエネルギーで動いてます
固めちゃったろう この 4つとは何ですか？ということで
出典はサンガティニカイのね
1番因果法則の経典群です
はい さっさと説明に行きます
1番目のエネルギー これは食べ物です
カベリカルワーロオーラーリコアスコマワ
第一はすごい分かりやすい
食べ物 粗きものであり
あれ 詳細なものであり
摂取するもの これ パーリ語のすごいだらしのない直訳なんです
で 摂取するもの これ 2種類あるんですよ
すごく粗い 粗いというかね
硬いものと精密に微妙なものというね
だから皆様はね あれ まあスープとかは精密な食べ物だとかね
ご飯とかは粗い食べ物やとかって
それはそうじゃなくて
人間食べるものはすべてこの粗っぽいものなんです
人間より次元の上の生命が食べるものは精密なエネルギーなんですね
だから食べるという風にも言えないんです
そこまで考えなくてもまあいいんでしょうし
とにかく 食べるものが何であろう
食べるものが第 1 のエネルギーなんです
生命の体の構成によって摂取する物質は変わります
これ 食べ物っていうのは物質なんですよ
だからどんな物質を食うのかっていうことは
あなたがどんな肉体を持ってるのかっていうことなんですね
例えばあなたは体見たらシロアリさんだよと
だから肉体はシロアリだったら食べるものはまあ木とかね
それも柔らかくて そういう木じゃないんですね
硬くて何年も経っている
食べているんですね で
ある肉体は毛虫ならもう葉っぱとか食べているしね
そういうことで この自分の肉体に合わせて食べる物質が変わるんですが
取るのは同じ物質なんです
仏教から見れば地水火風なんです
それでこの仏教ではね
神々 梵天とかいろいろ次元の話もありますから
そういう人々は何を食べますかね
日本の方々はね 神にお饅頭と酒をお供えするでしょ
あれ食って飲むと思いますかね
そんなこともね 酒飲んでお饅頭やら
また生のイワシとかね
魚とかね そのまま大根とか
そのまんまでね あんなのも食っちゃったら牛でしょうに
神というよりは だから実際はそんなものは食べませんよ
人間より次元高いの生命ですから食べません
まあ例えばね まあゴキブリとかネズミたちが
私に何か食べ物を持ってくる
これ食べてくださいと
食べると思う ネズミは一生懸命考えて
苦労に苦労をかけて この人に何か食べ物をあげなくちゃと持ってきたっても
人間である私はそれ食えませんね
あれはとっても優しい山羊さんがいてね
人間のこと困って この人は困っちゃったね
じゃあ私でも何か食べ物持ってきますと
いて 山羊さんがあちらこちらで美味しい食べ物を持ってくる
山羊さんにとって美味しいんだけど
あんな葉っぱ食えませんだからね
人間には そういうことで
肉体によって取る物質が変わります
それでお釈迦様が粗いものと詳細なものという風に分けてます
詳細なものっていうのは
まあかなり高度なエネルギーの波長なんですね
だから神々梵天は寿命は長いんです
だって我々食べる豆腐っていうのはもう 1週間も冷蔵庫に置いておけば 1週間ぐらいは持てますけどね
私の場合  1ヶ月半もありますからね
別に食べますよ で こんなすぐ足が早い食べ物を食べちゃうと
我々の命も同じこっちゃなんですよ
しかし 例えばまあ豆腐やら穀物といったっても
ほとんど炭素でしょ？カーボンでしょ
じゃあカーボンはどうですかね
寿命は 冷蔵保存保存でなきゃ腐る
そんなことないでしょ
カーボンも腐っちゃいますけど
これには結構時間かかります
そういうことで この例えば原子として見ればね
まあ例えばちょっとやばい
すごい早いんですけどね
まあ素粒子とか見ると
まあ寿命的には長くなっちゃうんですね
まあとにかくそれぞれの生命体
だから肉体という言葉は使えないんですね
肉体っていうのは もう我々地球上の生命だけだからね
だから生命体ですね 生命体の構成によって入れる物質
エネルギーです  1番目は肉体はないが
体を持っている神々 梵天も何かのエネルギーを取り入れているんです
2番目の色 これは即と言うんですね
パーリ語でパッサと言いますね
まあ即といっても なんかコンタクトという
パッソドゥティオ 即は 2番目です
この説明は眼耳鼻舌身意という感覚器官に色声香味触
一つ方がなくなっちゃった方というデータが触れることをパッセと言います
いたってわかりやすい
この触れること コンタクト
これがすごいエネルギーなんですよ
だから目耳鼻にデータが触れるんですよ
触れるたびにものすごいエネルギーが生まれるんです
すごいエネルギーが生まれるんです
あの こちらの三行目でね
ね ある色声 香 味 触 もう一つ
後というものは必要ですけど
なんか入れ忘れちゃったんです
だから感覚器官 6つで
触れるデータが 6つで
これ触れると触れると触れるとエネルギーが生まれる
あのマッチとあのマッチの箱の外
なんか薬のってますね
マッチがそちらに触れると
ちょっと触れただけですけどね
すごいエネルギーが生まれるでしょ
例えば太鼓ありますね
ちょっと手で振ってみたら
すごい音が出ますね だからちょっと指でトントンとやるだけで
トントンと指は鳴かないんだからね
でも 太鼓の面に触れるとすごいエネルギーが生まれるでしょ
では 人間の体にそんなぐらい力あるのかと
そうないんですけど 触れることによって新たに生まれちゃうんですね
はい このように この体っていうのはかなり発電所ですよ
目から耳から鼻から もう体全体でずっと生命エネルギーっていうものはもう生産されているんです
皆様  1 日何時間目を使ってますか？ 8時間だけ
仕事と同じ だからずっと目を開けて使ってるでしょ
すっともう発電していますよ
目を開けている間は限りなく
これはこの爆竹のエネルギーとかね
爆発のエネルギーとか比較になりませんだけど
例えば原発を爆発するとすごいエネルギーでしょ
あれにびっくりするんだけど
原発にはゴキブリ 1匹でも生かしてあげることできますかね
できないでしょ ただ壊すだけでしょうに
これ役に立ちませんよ
例えば子供にね 水入ってるガラスをあげちゃうと
これがこぼしちゃったり
ガラスまで割ったりするでしょ
子供の力はそんなところですよ
しかし そちらで大人が針に糸を通す
子供とエネルギーを使ってないようでしょ
使ってます すごいエネルギー使ってますよ
針の穴に糸を通すだけで
あらゆるエネルギーがあって
糸を通してもらう それが役に立つんですね
子供がもうガラスを落としちゃって割ったことでは何の役にも立ってないんです
だから原発もありますけど
原発 原爆がありますけど
原爆爆発するとものすごい
もう計算わかりませんだけどね
何メガトンとか何とかとかね
爆破エネルギーは生まれますけど
何の役にも立たない しかし
私たちは目は目を開けているだけで生きてます
ただ目を開けてるだけで
だから生きるエネルギーは目を開けてくれるでしょ
目が開けているんだから
どんどんエネルギーが生まれる
耳が聞こえているんだから
どんどんそのエネルギーは生まれる
だから 目が見えない方々にとってはエネルギーが足らないんだから
耳は倍働いてますでしょ
やっぱりちゃんと安定したエネルギー供給が必要なんです
だから目が不自由で生まれたら
なんのことか エネルギーはワンチャネルカットされてますね
それはやっぱり耳で 耳にバイパスするんです
聴覚で まあ耳だけでできませんよ
それも体で 観測で 指先で
すごく不思議なものは点字あるでしょ
あれ よく読むこと 私も目を閉じ
触ってみたらデコボコは感じますけど
これどうやって読むんでしたと
ということは 私の指先がすごく鈍い
だけど目の不自由な方々なんか触って読んで終わった
すごい早い そういうことで
このエネルギーを他のところを余分に働かせてますよ
でも頑丈ですよ 目が不自由な方々は
ある年齢に達ったら耳も聞こえなくなったとかないでしょ
そうはないでできます
そこでいろいろ弱くなって生まれて
補助チャネルもなくなっちゃうと
かなり悲しい人生になっちゃうんですね
だから目だけ不自由なんですけど
他の器官が働いていれば
全部そこは補助的に補給してくれるんですね
そちらもダメージを受けちゃうとどうなりましたと
もう結構生きていられなくなっちゃいます
早く逝っちゃいます はい
これでパス 触触れるコンタクトという至って簡単な単語なんですけど
これすごい意味で ものすごいエネルギーが生まれているんです
それによって認識が現れる
体に触れると 耳に触れると認識が現れる
生きるという働きが起こるんです
生きるということは認識があることなんですよ
はい  3番目のエネルギー
マノーサンチェータナタティヤ
意志職は3番目 意志職
なんか変な単語ですね
辞書にそうあったんです
生命に対する何かをしたいという意志があります
だから私は 1番目の意志使いたいんですけど
辞書には 2番目の意志なんですね
で それだったら物足らないんだから
意欲という単語も入れました
英語ではウィルインテンションなんですね
モーティフなんですね
ですから このウィルインテンションモーティフという
なんか日本語でモチベーションと言いますね
これは日本語の使い方はそれなりのモチベーションという意味があります
しかし モチベーションを辞書で引いてみると
辞書の意味 元の意味で取ってみればね
なんか生命に対する何かのモチベーションがあるんですよ
イライラしています 何かやりたい
このエネルギーなんですよ
3番目 座ったら立ったくなっちゃうしね
で こちらに講演あると宣伝したんだからね
では予約して話聞こうかなとね
聞きたくなるし 聞いてからまあ早く帰ろうとかね
こんな話は役に立たんやと
美味しい料理のレシピは今日テレビであるでしょうにとかね
ということになっちゃうんですよ
どうも いつでも何かやりたいんですね
まあ例えば指一本動かしたりとかね
こうやったりしたら その時でもやりたいという気持ちが生まれているんです
やりたいという頭の気持ちよりも
なんかエネルギーが生まれるんですよ
まあ例えばここら辺痒くなったとしますと
痒くなった途端に何かエネルギーが生まれてるんですよ
これで手が上がっていくんですよ
頭で考えてないんです
もう手が上がって もう動いてカチカチカチカチやってるんです
あれがモチベーションなんです
日本世間で言ってるモチベーションではなくて
辞書の意味のモチベーション
ザパワーオブデューモチベートという辞書の意味でね
だからまあ意欲にしましょうか
もうめんどくさいしね
何か意欲というか 意志というものがあります
これは 3番目のジオソ
諸法 このエネルギーに支えられて生きるという機能が起こるんです
これ難しい話ですけど
ブッダのすごいところは子供にもわかるんですよ
例えば 私はこういう歩きますね
歩きたい気持ちなかったら歩ける
今椅子を触ったでしょ
こういうところ 触りたいって気持ちあったんです
時々マイフォン 私がいる方向へぼんって変えたりするでしょ
やっぱり変えたかったんですよ
そういうわけでね まぶた閉じる時でもまぶた閉じたがってますよ
ちょこっと吸い飲み込む時でも
なんかエネルギーがあってやらせているんです
だからそう言ってちっちゃなところで考えましょうよ
まあ例えば私喋ってるんだから
こうやって手をこうやったりこうやったり
いろんなもう坊主として一番みっともない姿でまあ喋ってますけどね
で これも結局意志があってやらせてるんですよ
それで性格バレちゃいますね
性格ができてるならばね
そんなみっともない姿しないでしょ
そういうことなんですね
まあ講演中ね  真面目に聞く場合も
やっぱり意志があって
真面目に聞いてこれ勉強しようという気持ちがあってね
あ これはなかなか寝る暇はないんだから
この時間いいチャンスやと言って寝る場合もね
もあるしね どちらにしたっても
これ意志がやらせてるんです
各自の 意欲が下がると
うそのような激しい苦しみが起こるんです
何か何かやりたくてやりたくている時は元気なんですね
あのエネルギーが下がると
なんかうすにかかったような感じになるんです
エネルギーがなんかトラブっちゃったんです
これものすごく感じるんでしょ
私たちは このよく言うでしょ？なんかこのごろやる気がなくてとかね
その時状況最悪なんですよ
だからやる気満々の時はすごい自分的には気持ちいいでしょ
もし何か何かのことでやる気が失っちゃうと
もう大変ですよ もう 苦しいんです
それは やる気がなかったら
あんた休めと言えば簡単でしょ
あんたやる気ないの？では帰って休め
そういかないんで あれ
やる気なくなっちゃったから寝るぞと言えないんです
だから私はもう今日仕事をする気がなくなっちゃった
だから寝ると言ってはっきりエネルギーがあるんです
やる気があるんです  これやる気
意欲がなくなるとそうじゃなくて
なんか現代の言葉で言えばうつにかかったという感じなんです
うつ病も似ています このやる気ない状態
ちょっと中見るとうつ病なんですね
それでどういうことかというと
私たちはね まあ本を読んでいる
これで何かやる気がなくなっちゃうんですね
そうすると ガムを噛むか
おせんべい袋に手が行くかでしょう
あれをお茶は？お茶に手が行くか
あるいはこうやって背伸びするか
なんとかやるでしょ あれ
なんでやってるの？本を読んでいて
なんか読む気が下がっていくんですよ
それが苦しく感じるんです
それで新たにこうやって背伸びをしたりして
エネルギーを供給するんです
みんなやってます そんな難しい仏教哲学も知らないのに
だから知った方がいいんですよ
この行動 5つで生命にエネルギーを与えているんですよ
だからどこかの電圧が下がると
そこを調整しなくちゃいけない
はい 最後のエネルギー
これ難しい 最後の行動が色ですね
心ですね ヴィンヤーナンチャトゥッタン
色は 4番目です この場合の心とは認識です
心ですけど お釈迦様も時によって心に別名名をつけちゃうんですね
地蔵通し喋る場合は お釈迦様が色ヴィンヤーナという言葉を使うんです
マナスという言葉 チッタという言葉もありますけど
ヴィンヤーナといえば認識
認識といっても心には変わりありません
生命には認識が起きない瞬間はありません
皆様 何かあまりにも話が進まなくて
なんかもっと難しくする方はないのかというのは企んでます
で 椅子 椅子でも我々は認識しているんです
寝ている時でも認識しているんです
この認識イコール考えるではないんです
考えることは認識の一部だけです
食事とはたくあんわけじゃないでしょ
たくあんは 食事のほんのわずかな一部だけです
食事とは茶碗に盛ったご飯ですと
米ですと違いますよ 茶碗に盛ったご飯は食事のほんの一部だけですよ
また味噌汁はあるわ ひたしがあるわ
もう焼き魚もあるわね
もう何でしたっけ  コンビニの弁当しか知らないんだからね
えーとえーと 肉じゃがあるわとかね
そういうふうなことで
識なんですね 考えることも一部です
認識機能があるから生命です
この肉体で感じるから生命なんです
だから このペットボトルは生き物ではありませんでしょ
何も感じませんね 何も認識しません
私は生き物です 認識しているんだから
これがそうとやってます
止まらなく 認識の流れが切れるとは
その生命の死です 皆様方は考えることは認識だと思ったら
みんな寝たら死んじゃいますよ
だって考えることやめるでしょ
寝る時は 考えることではないんですね
考えることは一部であって
ずっと認識しています
止まることなく はい そういうわけで断食はありえないんです
コンセントを外したら機能しないでしょう
これ 一個じゃなくて行動
五本現象なんです  5本 5種類の現象なんです
あ 間違えた  4ですね 行動4種類なんです
ます物質の食べ物で これは太陽エネルギーですね
これだけはわかりやすい
物理学的エネルギーはワンチャネル
一つのチャネルで それから触れることやら
なんとかなんとかあります
忘れちゃったね 忘れちゃった
意思がありましてね 意識があります
で  3つですね そういうわけで
断食はありえませんよ
あれはとんでもない勘違いです
生命科学まるっきりわからんですよ
私は 2 日間ご飯食わないんだよと
だから何だと  1 秒も栄養なく体は持ちませんよ
2 日間ではなくてね もう 7
7 年間も勝手にやってくださいと
あのインドでネパールでね
なんか昔 何年か前でね
ある男の子がね 子供でしたけど
いきなりあの菩提樹 なんとかね
木に穴があってね 穴に入ってずっと瞑想してるんですね
だから信者さんがたくさん来て拝んだりしたりしてね
あの子はもう何も水も飲まないんだと
あまりにも大騒ぎするんだから
CNN のなんとかテレビ局がね
見張っていたんですね
2週間  3週間ぐらい  2週間かな
全部カメラつけて 赤外線カメラをつけて
夜でもこの子はどこかに行って
もう最低水ぐらいでも飲むだろうと
全然このカメラに入ってないんです
だから まあブッダですよと
ブッダの生まれ変わりですよ
その子はそれを否定しますし
仏教の人々もそれは否定するし
でも まあなんか体ぽっちゃりしていて
食べないわけにはね で
なんでしょうかというと
やっぱりその場合も あの子はすごい深く瞑想していますから
1週間  2週間座ったままでね
結核座したままでいるっていうのは相当なことですよ
だからエネルギーが入ってます
ただ食ってない 飲んでない
それだけ それで医者に医者は不思議や
これはどうしようもないんだとかね
ギネス記録もこの子は破っているのではないかと
でもその子は全然興味ない
そんなことには 何回も逃げたんですね
人々がたくさん来るんだからといって
逃げちゃって 森の中で
またどこかで穴の中に隠れてて見つかったりとかね
まあ今人気もないしどうかようわかりませんだけど
私もいい子だと思いますけどね
言いたいのは断食はありえない
だからこれ仏教的な断食なんです
食っていうのはアハラなんですね 4
種類なんですね 世間考えているのは食べ物だけなんです
あのミスどうするんですかね
だから心の栄養はすごくたくさんで
3種類ですからね これありえないんです
そこで科学的に見ても
アーハラのエネルギーを切ることは不可能です
切ることがなく流れるようになっているんです
切れることなど たまに食事をやめても断食は不可能です
たまたま朝ごはんを食べなかったとかね
いくらでもあるでしょ
でも断食はありえません
細胞は絶えず栄養をとっているんです
そこで私たちは 1 日 皆様は 3 食でしたら 6 食でしたっけ
あまり数えたことがないんでね
数えたら 18 食となる場合もありますからね
まあ一応基本的にはまあ 3 食にしましょう
まあそんなことを言ったっても
あんまり 3 食食う人もいないんですよ
ほとんど なんか頭おかしい
なんで 3 食にこだわるのかと
自分の国でもちょっと若者たちとかね
調べたんですけど 調べたわけじゃないんだけど
まあ話したりするとね
まあちゃんと 3 食食わなくちゃって偉そうなこと言うんだけど
よく見ると朝も食べてないし
まず元気なんですけど
何か私はいろいろ仕事を頼むんだからいいでしょってやっちゃうんですね
あとで私が思い立ったって
あのね あんた朝ごはん食べたのかと
いや 食べてないよと 今食べ今まあ 11時
12時だから言えるまでって
だから結局は朝ごはんも昼ご飯もなんかどうかで
もうお腹がグッドグッドしたらなんか食っちゃうだけでね
だから客観的にデータを取ってみると
必ず 1 日 3食ということはないんですよ
そこはなんかマンネリでやっちゃうと
それが病気なんですよ
だから私はレストランなんかで行くのはね
12時になる前だからいいんだけど
時々ご飯食べて 12時になる時もありますけど
なった途端 まあ一気にガッと人が入りますからね
あの時計に合わせて食わなかったら死んじゃうと思ってるんですかね
それっておかしいんですよ
はい その話を置いておいて
1 日 3食食べるというのは
これ哲学でも科学でもなんでもないんです
細胞はそう 栄養を取ってるんです
だから血液が流れてるでしょ
血液が流れるっていうことは
細胞は栄養を取ってるんです
これ止めちゃうと ですから
皆様方にいいアドバイスしますよ
日本でも結構断食自慢の方々いますよ
すごい断食してね こんなもうテーラワーダ仏教違って我々いっぱいやってますよ
だから提案してください
正しい断食 栄養をカットすることであると
だから心臓まで止めてくださいと
心臓鼓動してるんだったら
あんたインチキ断食やと
それでは神にもブッダにもなりませんと
だから心臓もやめてもらったら
まあ断食です また そこ意識認識は
切断不可能な働きです
そこでこの見えること
聞こえること 認識すること
考えること それは切断不可能なんです
まあ目だけをよく頑張りますから
閉じることできますよ
閉じた途端 他でもうパワーアップになるんです
エネルギーは同じ あの何を言うの？ボルテージで流れるんです
面白いでしょう まあ時々ね
皆さんはね 目とかね 時々おかしくなったりしてね
まあ目をなんとかして隠しておいたりとかね
で 目を閉じた途端 他の器官がすっともう働き出します
私の場合は 眠気っていうのは目にくるんですよ
で これでもう本読んだりするんだから
まあ眠くなっちゃって目が閉じるんですね
目が閉じる 自動的に閉じるところまで疲れちゃ眠くなっちゃったんだから
では寝るそうと言って
スタンドの電気消す 消す瞬間で他の器官が働き出すわ
もう眠れるところじゃないんですね
だから結局は電圧が同じ電圧で流れるんです
で 耳はストップすることはなかなか難しいしね
例えば あの 本当に音を遮断する
耳につけるいろんなものあるでしょ？綺麗に音を遮断するもの
イヤホンもありますよ
あの耳に挿しちゃうと
外の音は綺麗にカットされます
あのステレオと同じく
させてみてください どうなるのかと
もしヘッドフォンのあの音楽資源に入れてないんです
ただ ヘッドフォンだけ耳の中に挿しちゃったんですね
させた途端 すごい音を聞こえるんです
普段より ゴーゴーという音やら体の音やら骨の音やら
だってこの地球 まあいろんなところで音
振動あるでしょ あれ 振動は足の骨を通して
血液 液体通して入ってるんですよ
これ聞き出すんですよ
うるさいんですよ だから静かにいたければ
耳栓全部外していた方がいいんです
あれこれさせて音をカットすると
中の音がうるさくてたまらなくなっちゃうんですね
それで何言いたいかというと
このエネルギーは切断不可能
とにかく流れる はい これで 4番目に移いて
心がエネルギーですと
あるお坊さんの前でモーリヤパッブナというお坊さんなんですね
これは子供じゃないんです
このお坊さんがいるところで
お釈迦様がものすごい難しい因果法則の説法をなさったんです
あの今日参考にするのは一番も一番ではなくて
かなり難しい経典なんです
ああ だから私もなんか大学授業スタイルやらないとちょっと難しいんですよ
一般向けの講演みたいにはね
やるのはね とにかく内容難しい
色も生命を維持する食であると言ったら
食って食うものでしょ？とお坊さん考えるんですよ
誰がパンニャーナ食ってますかと
だからお釈迦様困っちゃったんですね
あのお釈迦様困ったところを読んで
私は再び再認識したんですよ
さすがお釈迦様が科学者であると
色は誰が食べるのかとお釈迦様に聞くんですね
だったらこのお坊さんがアーハーラ
食 食っていうのは取って食う
取って食うものだと思っているんですね
あの 掃除機に電気が流れることではないんです
掃除機が取って電気食ってるわけじゃないでしょ
エネルギーは別 のエネルギーに交換するだけ
電気が流れてモーターが回転して
それでいくつかのエネルギーに変わるんですね
それで終わり それにお釈迦様は食という単語を使っているんです
だからアーハーラっていうのは思い出しました
インプットなんです インプットという言葉ご存知でしょうね
パソコンにデータインプットするとか
だからインプットアウトプットというね
まあ現代よく使っている言葉があるでしょう
アーハーラというのはインプットのことなんですね
だからインプットするとそれなりにアウトプットがあります
アウトプットは生きているんです
だからお釈迦様はこの昔
こんな単語ないでしょう
結構困っちゃったんですね
まず言ったのは 誰が食うかという質問が間違ってますよと
質問自体が間違っているとお釈迦様が答えるのです
誰という語は因果法則によって成り立ちません
誰が食ってるわけじゃないんですよ
あの時々 西洋の人々も私と喧嘩したことありまして
昔々ね で 昔も百年昔ではありませんよ
百年まだ年取ってないんだから
で  やっぱり誰かがやらなくてはいけないんだと
皆思ってるんですね それはいりません
だからインプットがあれば
そこでアウトプットができるんですよ
色はどのように触になるのかとは正しい質問です
とお釈迦様はもう教えるんですね
で 色だから お釈迦様の場合は色
あるいは食べ物というものは滋養になる
パソコンのキーボードを叩くと
各キーが番号を持ってますね
その番号が CPU の中に入っちゃうんです
番号で言っても電気信号なんですよ
私は B 押したらパソコンの中に B が行くわけじゃないんです
何かの 0 1 0 1 の番号が行くんですね
電気信号として それでまたその数字を B という画像にする場所もあって
それがモニターで B という画像にして見せてくれるんです
だからただエネルギーの流れだけなんです
だからお釈迦様がそれは色
どのように？例えばこのスクリーンに
なぜこの 11 という数値が映しているのかと
どのように映しているの？これ誰が映したんですか？と聞いちゃうとおかしいでしょ？私が映したと思う
違う じゃあ佐藤さん 誰もやってないんです
ただ それぞれのインプットによって
こちらで 11 というアウトプットが現れたんです
はい まあ難しい話じゃましょう
その答え ヴィンヤーナーハーロ
アイティン プナッハワービニッバッティアパッチョよ
色色は再び生まれ変わることの原因になる
ああ これ書かなかった方がよかったなって
今更悩んだってもね で
結構難しい あの色っていうのは
このエネルギーがあって
生命が生き続けている
その四の中で色認識というエネルギーが特別に死んでくたびれて死んでも
またエネルギーをスタートするんです
めんどくさいんですよ
例えば目が壊れちゃったらそこで即死したでしょ
音を聞きたくなければね
耳を壊しちゃえばね 簡単ですけど
色はそうじゃないんです
色は色を作るんです 心は瞬間瞬間に生じて滅するのです
生滅の流れです 隙間がないんです
死という瞬間も色です
次に再び生という瞬間が起こるんです
あの あれ 何と言いますか
あの なんかあの 玉を何か 2つの線で並らぶら下がっておいて
1個の玉 こうやって当たったら前の玉出るでしょ
あれ何て言いますか あの道具に道具じゃない
あれはまあアクセサリーみたいにね
振り子ですか 振り子たくさんつなげたような感じね
皆様結構見たことありますね
あの糸で玉も 6個  8個ぐらい
あの こうやって線にぶら下がっておいて
あれ ぴったし こうやって
それ一個だけ引いちゃうで
こちらの糸と飛んでいくんですね
これ飛んでこっちのやつ
ここ飛んでいっちゃうんですね
まあ振り子でもよろしいし
だから上がって下がって
下がったら上がる 上がったら下がるという感じなんです
これどうにもならんです
振り子で考えたら 振り子が左に行っちゃったら必ず右に行く
右に行っちゃったら じゃあ左に行けと
そのように この心の場合は
式の場合は初滅 初滅 初滅であるならば初初であるならば滅
瞬間におきる すごい速い
電気 光のスピードよりははるかに速い
物質ではないんだから
だから困ったこと 輪廻転生するんです
すべての生命は だから輪廻転生論というのは仏教
ブッダの仏教から見れば
すごく精密な科学的な教えなんです
信仰的なものではないんです
エネルギーの論なんです
これはどうにもならん
生じたら滅する 滅したら生じると
はい アーハーライコール存在イコール輪廻なんです
正しい食事生活について学ぶより先に
上の等式を理解するべきです
それと等式というんです
育児者の イメチャッタールーアーラータンハニダーナ
またちょっとテーマが変わります
この 4つの色は何の原因にしているんですか？と
はい では 4種類のエネルギー資源があります
電気コード 4種類 この電気はなんで生まれるのかって次の問題なんです
タンハサムディアタンハジャティカタンハパバワと
言葉 3つ使ってるんですが
日本語の単語はありません
渇愛は原因 渇愛により生じる渇愛は元です
渇愛という何かしら変なものがあるんです
この変なものがあるんだから
エネルギーは生まれるんです
ということは 我々は渇愛があるんだからご飯を食べているんです
渇愛があるんだから見たり聞いたりしているんです
渇愛があるんだから 体で刺激を欲しがるんです
渇愛あるんだから思考しているんです
渇愛あるんだから生きているんです
渇愛のことはね 時々私は脳を使って説明する場合がありますからね
原始脳である生存欲 生きていきたいと
それも欲ですけど これもアハーラですけど
ある程度では ファンクションは違いますからね
無明と存在欲 渇愛 心の本来の状態は無明と渇愛です
心から発するエネルギーは
1 触色  2 意色  3 色心 心からこの 3種類のエネルギーを生まれるんです
渇愛から だから皆様も私もずっとこの触色
意色 色即という専門用語使っちゃうとね
難しくなりますけど ただ触れたらエネルギーが生まれる
何かやりたいというよね
いつでもあるし それでエネルギーが生まれる
それから色認識する 認識しないでいられない
これが相当エネルギーなんです
これ渇愛から生まれるんですよ
脳で言えば原子脳から生まれるんです
原子脳はいくらでもエネルギーを作るんです
生まれたら体があります
それで死気が死んじゃったら新しく生まれるでしょ
次にそこで体が放り込むというか
体がなんて言いますか
に囲まっちゃうんです
式が どんな体かわかりませんだけど
それぞれ生命体に合わせた何か物質が認識を囲まっちゃうんです
認識が物質の中に隠れるんです
だから私にこの肉体がないと認識することはできないんです
この肉体の中に認識が隠れているんです
肉体とは物質です 炭素やら水素やら
まあそんなもんなんです
窒素やらね みんな知ってます
でもこの肉体 炭素やら水素
酸素などなどでできていると言ったっても
なんか変なものが起きてますね
認識するという認識が隠れて生かしているんです
で 体が生まれたら体に物質的な食が必要です
だから肉体はものでしょ
ものが壊れると部品が必要ですね
修理するために 四色は
新たな色を作ります これ
別なところにいるべきタイトルテーマなんですけど
はい 四色 四種類の食べ物がありまして
この四種類の食べ物は次から次へと食べ物を作るんです
認識すると次の認識が生まれる
そうすると次の認識が生まれる
例えば 今日はちょっと寒いなと認識するでしょ
ついでに別なもう 1枚着てよかったなとか出てくるでしょ
次から次 ちょっと喉が渇いたなと認識するでしょ
次に何か飲めばよかったなと次の思考が生まれるんです
だから一個の式が生まれたとは
次の式も次の式も次の式も生まれる
目に何か触れたとは 次に次に次にまた触れるエネルギーが生まれる
そういうことで 四色があることで無限に尚色六文殊なんだからなんだらという
あの化け物を作りたがってるでしょ
日本は あんな感じでいくらでもエネルギーが生まれる
恐ろしい仕組みなんです
減らないんですよ 増えることがあっても
増えることがあったっても
容量がありますからね
容量で漏れます エネルギーは余分に作っちゃうとかなりやばくて
自己破壊するか他破壊するかどうか分からないんです
で というわけで 食べるものについて困らないでください
これ 自動発生するんですよ
いくらでも エネルギーは無限に投げれます
だからこの生命は四色
四つの色のアーハールの説明で
輪廻転生は科学的に証明できるところなんです
残念ながら 生命はそういうからくりだよと科学者はまだ発見していないんです
お釈迦様はこの難しくてね
この経典群がすごい難しいんですよ
難しいと こちらだけ輪廻転生の話が因果法則に乗っ取って教えるところです
だからエネルギーの無限牢になってしまうんですよ
一旦 仏教の地理学的な仏教
科学的な色は終わりました
体には玄米よろしいか
白米よろしいかっていうテーマではなかったね
それ聞きたかったですよね
欲と怯えが食事習慣を占領している
えっと 皆様 もう休み取りたければ
疲れたならば 何か喉が渇いたらどうですか？お父さんいないんですか？まあ
ちょこっとテーマが一応新しいテーマになりますからね
では あの じゃあ 10分程度にします
はい では始まります これからは簡単です
それほど難しくないんです
人間の食事 生活について
欲と怯えが食事習慣を占領しているんです
私たちはしっかり理性的にご飯を食べているわけじゃないんです
かなり人質にされちゃって
で それから何て言いますか
あれは身代金払ってるような気分で
食事を取っているんです
決してありがたい話ではないんです
目的は逸れている 食べる時
我々は目的は逸れてるんです
はい 体のためであると知っているが
食事は人間にとって最大の楽しみです
これがおかしいんですよ
楽しむために食べるんじゃないんです
これ 全然楽しいことじゃないんです
あの車にガソリンを入れることは超楽しい
食事を取ることによって
欲 見栄 傲慢 怒り 自我などの煩悩を掻き立てて増やすんです
欲で食べてるんです 見栄で食べてるんです
友達に自慢するために
フランス料理屋に行って食べたりする
テレビで宣伝したらもう 3時間まで並んでるんですね
ラーメン食うために 相当病気ですよ
あれは 何々有名人があの店に行くんだと聞いたら
まあ行くわ 行くわという感じで
何やってるのかと もう科学的なところはもう飛んでるんですね
だから自我を張るために食べてるんですよ
これとんでもないこと
だから食べるものは全部悪くなっちゃいます
まあ例えば車をちょっと褒めてあげようと思ってね
ガソリン入れる時はね
まあギター弾いて歌一曲歌って
またもうなんとかトゥイスティングでもして踊ってあげたら車喜ぶ
燃費は良くなる まるっきり無駄でしょ
だからこれはわかりやすく言えば
この包丁は大事に食料を切るためにあるものですけど
包丁を見るたびにすごくピカピカ光っちゃってかっこいいんだから
まあ子供たちにあげて
じゃあこれで遊んでくださいと
子供たちはプラスチックでできている刀を持ってね
まあ相手とだとかやってるでしょ
さっさと今日から あのね
こんなプラスチック これ刀でもなんでもないんだからね
最低包丁でも使ってくださいと
あの 3歳の子供たちにあげてください
それで二人で決闘やってくださいと
って何やってるんですかね
これで 同じことを我々は食べる時やってるんですよ
欲で見栄で 嫉妬で 怒りで
憎しみで 落ち込みで で
食べている 摂取も煩悩の大きな資源です
ですから 私たちはおにぎり 1個食べたっていうことは
その分 体心の煩悩も増えちゃって
心が汚れたってことなんです
結構ひどい穴に落ちてますよ
おにぎりではなく うなぎ弁当になったら
昼ご飯はもう結構煩悩が増えてます
科学的に食べてほしいんです
この私は何でも嫌味言うように皆様感じるでしょ
あれは嫌味言うのは簡単じゃないんですよ
すごく客観的に観察しなくちゃいけないんです
だから私も日本に来てから 1回
2回ぐらいはラーメン食べたことあります
それっきり食べないんです
こんな恐ろしい塩やあれやこれやとか
強烈な味付けて あれにそれに麺入れてね
ズルズルと食べて あれも飲んだりしてて
これ死んじゃいますよと
これで 死ぬために食べるんじゃないんだよと
テレビの料理番組は結構見れますよ
それ見て自分でも料理作って食べてますけど
まあすごく美味しく出来上がります
私には食べられませんだけどね
美味しすぎて もうどうしても捨てる羽目になります
が まあテレビの番組見て
絶対この真似だけはしませんと決めます
だから 例えばおにぎり 2つ食べるか
昼ご飯に あるいはうなぎ弁当食べるかというと
それ分 煩悩が増えるんですよ
これものすごく  5  6  7
8  19年前か話ですけど
なんか私がもういろいろもうコンビニばっかり食べていて
なんか体調が悪くて弱くて
なんかいきなり無性にうなぎ食べた方がいいんじゃないかなと
なんとなく自動的になんか欲求が出てくるんですね
あれ うなぎ食べなくちゃと
その日で行って うなぎ弁当買って食べたんですね
その日で まあ結構美味しく感じたんです
もうそれからもうなぎ食べたことは 2 3回ありますけど
なんだこりゃっていう感じなんです
別に大したことないでしょ
大した味が別にないんですよ
まあまあ甘いしね で 焼き魚ってどちらでもだいたい同じ味というかね
まあ魚によって微妙な差があるんだけど
焼き具合やらね で 客観的に食べると
そんなに夢中になることがないんですよ
うなぎ食ったぞって言いたい
言いたいために食べると
あれが子供が包丁で遊んでいることなんです
楽しみであるはずの行為は
限りのない悩みと苦しみの種になっているんです
それで食べることは楽しみであるはずですけど
今は食文化がありまして
単にお薬の食べ料理がありまして
それぞれの食べ物の食べ方がありまして
食べる時の道具もあるはあるわね
で スイカ食べる時はこの道具やとかね
メロン食べる時はこれやとかね
もうリンゴ食べる場合はこの道具やとかね
で 西洋的に食べる場合も
ナイフは何種類か フォークは何種類か
スプーンは何種類かってあるんですね
これって結構苦しいんだと思いますよ
皆様もこの料理についてかなり苦労していると思いますよ
大根の切り方どれぐらいある？そこは問題なんです
大根料理はたくさんありますね
その料理に合わせて切りが変わっちゃうんですね
キャベツ使う料理もたくさんありますね
それに合わせてキャベツの切り方が違う
食べ方も変わっていく
ロールキャベツなんかはまあそのままもう取って食べることできないし
フォークしたっても フォークをそのまま食べることはできませんしね
それはちゃんと切って食べなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうしね
千切りにしたもうキャベツだったら
まあやっぱり箸で食べられるしね
だからそのようにあらゆるものは出来上がっちゃうんでしょ
あれは何のためだと思う？煩悩のためなんです
身体のため 健康のため？まるっきりないでしょ
ただ気持ちいいでしょ
気分的に そのためなんです
いわゆる心に刺激をあえて与えたいんです
あえて煩悩をかき立てたいんです
だからブッダの真理を知らない人は
食べるたびにかわいそうで
結構罪を犯してます だって心汚してますからね
罪とは人をぶん殴ることだけじゃないんですよ
人と喧嘩することだけじゃないんです
そんなの大きな罪じゃないんです
喧嘩したっても ごめんねと仲直りしましょうというのがチャラですからね
そんなに根深い罪になりませんよ
死後まで追ってこないんです
自分がもう人と喧嘩しちゃって
怪我させちゃっても まあそれから一生懸命面倒見てあげて
すごく仲良くしてあげて
親しい人になってしまっちゃえば
良いことをしたことになっちゃうんです
あれは消します 悪行為は
しかし 私たちは毎日やっている
これは何なのかと なんで余計に心汚して地獄に行く道作るんですかね
食べることは避けられない
誰にだって お釈迦様であっても
食は 4種類です これから逃げられないんです
だからって言って罪を犯す必要ないでしょ
はい 解決しましょう 解決はいたって簡単
もともとの意味を理解しましょう
食べる前に 食べる時 壊れてゆく肉体を修復するために材料に過ぎないのです
主語はないんだけど 食べるものをね
食事とはなんです？食事とは
壊れてゆく肉体を修復するための材料に過ぎないのですと
これ暗記して覚えてください
毎日善行することになっちゃうんです
食事は幸福を招くようになるんです
招く猫はいりません 他何の目的でも食べてるわけじゃないんです
体が壊れるんですよ このパソコンがそんな簡単には壊れませんし
他の物質は簡単に壊れませんだけど
一番簡単に壊れるのは生命の物体なんですよ
理由はこれ心が作ったんだからなんですよ
すごい不安定な心が作ったものだから
遺伝子は壊れるんです
細胞は壊れるんです 簡単に
それで新たな物質を持っていて
新たなカーボンやら水素やら炭素やら
鉄分やらもう入れてまた作らなくちゃいかんですね
全体的にそこを理解しておけば
煩悩はかき回せないんです
いたって簡単ですよ 解決策は
体が体壊れると力がなくなると苦しみが生じるんですね
もう一つ 体が壊れると
なんかやけに苦しい それから体に力がなくなると
例えば足がうまく動かないと歩くと苦しいでしょう
だからそれにエネルギー入れてほしいんですね
これは摂取することでなくなります
体を放っておいた後 結構苦しいんです
あの余計な苦しみをなくしましょうと
これ 2 行目ですよ 呪文に
呪文の 2 行目です これ呪文みたいなもんです
呪文よりは効き目があります
心はものすごい綺麗になります
1番目は壊れている行く体を修復するための材料 2
番目は体が苦しくなります
その苦しみをなくすための薬ですね 3
番目 必要から欠かせないから食べるのであって
決して美味しいから食べてはならない
この食料はこの肉体に欠かせない
必要です ですから入れます
あ これが美味しい だって食っちゃいますと
ダメなんです あ これはなんだかんだ有名な店で買ったんですかね
あれを一度食べたかったんですねとか
ダメです あれ このリンゴ
リンゴありますね すごい高い
1万円ぐらいのね かな
なんか見たことがあります
ばっかり高いリンゴ きっとまずいだと思いますけどね
で これ 1万円もかかるリンゴやと
これ特別にこれでこれで手加えてこうやってこうやって作ったものやと
と言ったら 不味くてもみんな美味しいと錯覚起こすんですよ
あのコマーシャルバリューですね
で テレビで宣伝しちゃうとどうせ美味しくなっちゃうんですね
これ病気ですよ 自分で材料を見て調べればね
全然このマインドコントロールに乗らないでください
何々店のほうれん草は断然美味しいという風じゃなくて
その時そのいろんなところで手に入ったほうれん草を持って帰って食べてみて
どんな味かな どんな味かな
チェックすればいいでしょうに
だってほうれん草っていうのは毎日作るものだから
同じ味じゃないんですよ
あの店の品物は信頼できるぞと言ったっても
これはありえないんですよ
そういうことで  3番目の項目は欠かせないから食べてますと
という意味なんです これもの
これ私は簡単に言いますけど
すっごいすっごい深い重大な意味なんです
人間の思考は逆転させなくちゃあかんです
人間に幸せをもたらすならば
今の食べ方はもう世界中のね
とんでもない悪いんですよ
ただ 貧しい国々で食べるものがなくて
食べるものを見たらパッと飛んで取って食べるでしょ
動物みたいに あれが正しいんです
あれで病気になりません
大丈夫です その場合は必要だからでしょ
欠かせないでしょうね
食べ物はない  1日 2日
3日  1週間も食べてない
それでちょこっと食べ物いたら
キャーっと言って奪い合って取ったり食べたりする
なんか動物のように見えるかもしれませんだけど
その人は見栄のために食べてないでしょ？自慢するために食べてないでしょ
有名な店だから食ってないでしょ
食べなかったら死んじゃいますから
だからかなりの前 アフリカでね
すっごい乾季状態があって
で もう国連の穀物とかね
もうヘリからいてポチャンと落としちゃうんですね
まあ危険だからどうかはわかりません
それで砂の上でトウモロコシやらばら子供たち拾ってこうやって食べるんです
あれを見たんですからね
ものすごい残酷な もう見ていられない姿ですけど
人間でしょうにと思いますけど
なんでいくらでもあんな風にするのかいと
しかし あの砂に の中に落ちてて
人はその上に走ったり踏んだりもするのに
あの飢えている子供たちがこうやって拾って拾って
トウモロコシ 1個1個食べたりして
あれではまあ悲しいことなんですけど
病気になりません それでもさらにスイートコーンというものは作って
これは特別に柔らかく作ってもらって
その上バターも乗り上がって
もともと甘いのに砂糖もかけて
丁寧に輪切りにしてもう取って食べると
これはもう贅沢だと思ってるでしょ？煩悩ですね
心は汚れているんです
これで健康が崩れます
体にも毒になるし 心も悪を犯していることになります
これ 何のこともない 犯す悪の量がありすぎなんです
悪を犯した覚えがないんです
だから地獄にいたら閻魔様を恨むでしょうね
まあこれはまあ神話物語ですけど
なんで閻魔さんが俺を地獄に落とす
私は悪を犯した覚えはないでしょうとかね
閻魔さんにどうすることもできないんです
はい それで3番目の項目を覚えておきましょう
必要だから食べています
これ 今皆様に紹介しているのは
お釈迦様が出家に教えられた
出家だけに教えられたものなんですよ
だからもったいぶって言わなくたっていいんですけど
そこから全部皆様に合わないんだから
合うところは編集して今紹介しているんです
心清らかなままで 何の隅に隅にも汚れることなく食べる方法
その上 体の健康も維持する
私たちは暗記していますよ
お寺に入ったらまずそれを暗記させます
一番最初に だって サッベーサッターハラティティカだから
すべての生命は食によって成り立ってますからね
出家してお寺に入ったら
まずこの食べることやらいくつかありまして
それを暗記させるんです
本を開けて読んだらダメなんです
暗記で しかし 公では唱えません
これで解決策3項目でありました
至って簡単でしょう あの前の話と随分違うでしょう
実践編は 今日から皆様は別に食べ物を選ばなくてもいいんです
聞いてください この肉体にこれが必要ですか？と
20センチぐらいソフトクリームやらもうバターやらもう積み重ねているケーキがあって
そこら辺はリンゴを一つ二つもあってね
まあ切ったリンゴをね
この肉体にどちらが必要でしょうかと
自分がこれからすごい重労働をする予定だったら
あのケーキ食べて一向に構わないでしょ
これから寝る予定だったらリンゴにするしかないでしょ
それだけの話なんです
で 英語で言えばザチェック
ザネセシティなんです
ケーキがあって アイスクリームがあってとかね
またいくつかの甘いもの並んであって
チェックする この肉体に必要でしょうかと
ただ 今日はご飯も食べたし
ポテトチップポテトも食べたし
だったら要りませんということになるでしょ
しかし欲があるとダメでしょ
やっぱり私はこのケーキだね
食べたいねとかね 美味しいですねとか
これは有名な あの スイーツ作る人は何て言いますか
あの え？え？パティシエ
これ有名なもうパティシエが作ったものだから
やっぱり食べてみなきゃ損やと
食べることが損なんです
あのオーストラリアのある人が
これテレビで見た話で
クックさんなんですね
若い子くて これでどんどんどんどんどんどんゾウさんみたいに太るわ太るわ太るわ
自分では体がもうコントロールできないところまで
しかし 本人は専門職でしょうし
プロでしょうしね 困りましたと
こんなことで ただ 本人ある日発見したんですね
自分がいろんな新しい作品
料理作るんです 作って自分で食べてみなきゃダメでしょ
このお客さんに出すものだから
毒に決まってる  ものすごいカロリーやらコレステロールやらありったけのものはね
入れちゃいますから それ化学調味料やらね
で その人もまず食べてみるんですね
それで太るんですね それでその人
それから何やったかというと
ちゃんと作って ちゃんと食べて食べてみるんですよ
口で食べて味わって 歯触り
全部チェックして そのままバケツがあって
それにペロッと出すんです
食べません 口の中で全部チェックして
それは仕事だから それからペロッと出す
それからやっと健康を取り戻して
体重を取り戻したと だからテレビで前と今
ビフォーアンドアフターの出ていましたからね
私はその人が仕事したいし
プロでしょうし プロのプライドもあるしね
だから体健康がなくなったんだから
仕事辞める羽目になったというと情けないでしょ
見つけたんです 方法は
情けないではなくて しっかりした方法
だから自分がスマートな体で結構ごちそうすること出すと
みんなこいつは作ってるんだから毎日食ってるでしょうねと思っちゃうでしょ
だから俺たちも食べましょうよと
これで商売も上がっちゃうし
そこでものすごい 2メートルぐらい横幅があるクックさんがケーキ持ってて出すと食う
本当に私の場合はもう食欲なくなりますよ
時々 まあたまにまあ高級レストランなんか行ったりしてね
まあ日本であんまりないんですけど
まあこのシェフが時々来るんですね
で 来てちょっと話したりして
で 何回も一回あったんです
まあシェフが来たら 私もやっぱりせっかく料理作ったんだからといってね
まあもう挨拶をしてちょっと話したりしますけど
まず見るのはこの人の体なんです
体見てから 私はどの程度で食べるべきかと
美味しいんだからとは食いません
はい その3項目を覚えておいてください
覚えてください 暗記してください
私の文章はちょっとね
気持ち悪いんですけど
できるだけ美しい文章にして暗記してください
はい 次 あの四 四具と最低限
これもすごい大変大事なことなんです
あの四具っていうのは欠かせない 4つですね
着るもの 食べるもの 住むところと薬
命を支えるために 最低限をしっかり理解して把握しておく
それがあれば満足 足りることを感じられるように精神的に成長する
で 食べるものの場合はもうすごい厳しいんだけど
例えば着るもの 何か着るものがあれば十分やと
それで満足を感じる その上
美しいものを着られる
色のいいものを着られる
肌触りの良いものを着られると最高に喜べばいいんです
過ぎてるんだと 空腹空をなくして
満腹空が生じないようにする
はい 食べるものに対しても同じことで
最低限で まあこれぐらいあったら生きられると
まあそれより 2つ食べまったと
ああ 十分ですねとかね
という感じで喜びを感じればいい
次の項目はこの空二つ
空腹空と満腹空 空腹空をなくして
満腹空が生まれないようにする
以上です それで終わり
食事習慣が難しい話になっちゃうと覚えられませんだからね
で 健康に入ります 完全な健康体はまれしかありえない
だから期待しないでください
食いまくって健康になるとかね
食いまくったっても 食べるものにはすごい気をつけたっても病気になりますから
これは無駄です しかし
健康でなければ生きることに障害が生じる
お釈迦様もアーロギャパラマーラーバ
健康であることは最大の徳であると
これ損得の徳なんです
説かれています お腹が空いた時のみ食べるならば
とりあえず OK です 簡単でしょう
ちゃんと時間に食うっていうことは世間で言ってますけど
あれは私があんまり良くないと思いますよ
それぞれ体が違いますから
まず食べる それからお腹が空くまでます
お腹が空いちゃって グーグーと鳴り出すとすると
ちょっと水をちょっと飲んでから食べれば
またいつ食べるかというと
またお腹が空くまで待つと
これ実行 まあ難しいんだけど
まあ健康の問題ないんです
この食べたことじゃなくて
このお腹が空いたという感覚は細胞に必要なんです
細胞は休めないんです
休ませてあげると長生きします
だから長生きする秘訣は空腹感なんです
はい それであの それだけで足りません
空腹感をちょっと楽しんだ方がいいんですね
食うことだけではなくて
お腹が空いてることは楽しんでみれば
私はそれ実験して言ってるんですよ
あの空腹感になると結構楽しいんですよ
それで体がすごく軽く動くんです
何か食べてるよりは体力が出てくるんです
疲れがなくなって 疲れなくなっちゃうんですね
それでもうクタクタ 疲れ
もうお腹が空いちゃって
まあもうダメやというところで食べればいいんです
ダイエットは失敗ですね
この言葉は食事 生活について
人間だけが大きなミスを犯したことを物語っています
このダイエットという言葉があってはならない言葉なんです
ありえない あってはならない言葉なんです
節度を知って節制すれば済む話です
食べるものと煩悩が合体している
失敗することも避けられないんですね
だからみんな失敗しますよ
食べることで だからダイエットする羽目になります
もしダイエットすることになっちゃったら
まあ人生失敗なんだ あれは
だからダイエットも失敗するでしょ
だって長い間の癖だからね
だからダイエットしないように気をつけてください
ダイエットする羽目になったって言ったら
人格は問われます 煩悩でストレスで食べては食べないこと
ちゃんと空腹になるまで待って
今できるでしょ？チンすればね
料理作ってからもう食べる人は食べて
私の分は置いといてくださいと
空腹になったらもうチンして食べれば
そうするとまずいと思っちゃうでしょ
あれ 煩悩なんです 美味しいんだから食ってるんじゃなくて
必要だから食べてるんです
はい それからハランとハラール
これはイスラム教の言葉ですけど
禁止と許可 宗教は まあ時間なくなっちゃったんだから
このセクションはカットしたってもいいと思いますけど
宗教は人間に食べられるものを禁と許に分けるんですね
私は腹が立ちます それ人間食べられるものを並んで
これは禁止 これは許可っていうのは
なんだこれはと 毒キノコ
フグの肝 トリカブトなどを禁止するならば理性的ですが
仏教の心理から見ると
食そのものが苦しみを司る原因なんですよ
だったら食うなかれというならば
全部食うなかれなんです
認識もするなかれなんです
体で感じることもやめてよと
考えることもやめてちょうだいと
だからそこは極限で そんな教えてないんですけど
なんで人間に食べられる栄養なのに
豚肉食べてはいけないんですかね
なんで人間に食べられる栄養になる牛は食べてはいけないんですかね
日本ではないんだけど
いろいろ宗教ではそういう項目
厳しくあるんですよ しかし
避けて通らない問題でもありますね
これもいわゆる避けて通らないっていうのは
この食事しなくちゃなんですよ
食事することで そんなにありがたいことじゃないんです
苦しみの延長ですよ で
出家は自分のために殺す
殺されたことを殺されたという疑いある
肉魚が禁止です お釈迦様も食べてはいけないことはおっしゃってますよ
これは出家に教えています
皆様にはないんです 私たちには食べてはいけないことはあります
何かというと 肉か魚か
例えば私のために 絞めたならばダメです
あんた来ると言ったんだから
もう昨日うなぎ買っておいたんだよと
で 朝作りましたよと たら
そのまでうなぎが水の中にいて
私が来る時は首を切っちゃったんだから
これは食べられないんです
それから ゾウ 馬 虎 熊 肉食系の動物ですね
ヘビなども禁止しています
これも出家に皆様食べてください
それの解脱に関わる問題ではないんです
クマの肉を食べたら悟れませんということじゃないんです
ただ品格が問われるんですね
当時で王様がすごい怒るんですよ
ゾウの肉とか馬の肉とかね
食べちゃうと 王の財産だから
在家に対しては何も説かれてありません
お釈迦様かっこいいでしょう
食べるものを勝手に区別しちゃって
禁と教と 迷惑でしょうに
人がもう植えているならば
何でも食っちゃってもいいでしょうに
何やってるんですかね
そういう方々は で 出家しているんだから
我々お釈迦様はね まあ我々慈しみ実践しなくちゃあかんでしょ
だから私の目の前で あれ
タンクから魚を取って
じゃあこれ焼きますって言ったら
私はすぐ出てさようならと
冷凍庫から取ってきたら別に OK なんですね
これは私 食うために殺しちゃうんではなくて
もう売るために殺しちゃって
もう冷凍庫で何ヶ月か回るものだからね
殺生してはいけないだけです
在家に言っているのは
殺生してはいけないと
はい 菜食主義にも喋るデーヴァダッタが出家に戒律として菜食主義を提案したが却下されました
デーヴァダッタのお釈迦様に反対した反逆的な行為をやったお坊さんなんです
で 親戚でもあった 彼が出家は死ぬまで菜食主義であるべきですと
戒律を作ってくださいとお釈迦様に言ったんで
お釈迦様は却下 理由 戒律は聖学者でが定める
誰にもその権利はありません
我々 2500 年間出家する習慣があるんだけど
戒律は作りません 作れません
お釈迦様が決めた戒律だけです
菜食主義 森に住むこと
紛争へを着るなどは各自で自由に行えばよろしいと
お釈迦様はそう言う 特別に何かやりたければ
どうぞご自由にと あるお坊さんが私は絶対菜食主義でいきますと言ったら
はい どうぞと だからそのお坊さんにこれ戒律にしましょうと
他のお坊さんたちも菜食主義でなければダメと言っちゃうと
あなたは戒律を犯してますよということになるんです
それが各自自由 ブッダは科学的に食べ物を体を維持する材料として考えたんです
お釈迦様は食べ物っていうのはただの材料だと思っただけなんです
肉も魚も人体を維持する材料なんですよ
ただ殺生してはならない
そこで死んじゃった肉破片がもう運命がないでしょ
腐るしか これ食べて元気になる
何があるんですかね 別に私はもうそんな好きわけじゃないんですけど
一応論理的にはそういう話なんです
食事とは 植物が動物を摂取することです
植物 植物か なんですね
動物を これ我ではないんです
食事っていうのは 植物を食べるか
動物を食べるかでしょ
果物以外 誰に食べてもらう？誰かに食べてもらうプログラムではないんです
キャベツは人間様に食べてほしいと思っていないんです
魚は人間に食べてほしいと言って取っているわけじゃないんです
果物は別です 果物は食ってもらいたいんです
だって ブドウに何のためにあれがあるんですかね
誰か食べるためでしょ
ただ ブドウは種だけまいてくださいと
ブドウのするのね 面倒を見てあげてくださいと
子孫を残してくださいと頼む
その仕事をやってますからね
人が作って残したもの
いらないものをいただく
托鉢習慣は出家に推薦します
お釈迦様が食べることは怪しいんだから
食べる事自体苦しみの延長だから
出家に托鉢しなさいと言ったんです
なぜかというと キャベツ
ジャガイモを食べても
キャベツさんもジャガイモさんも嫌がってますよ
奪って食べてるでしょ
どうしようかと それでお釈迦様が出家だけに在家ではないんです
人がご飯炊いて ジャガイモも茹でて食べた
まだ一寸とこと残っている
これ捨てるしかないでしょう
そうするとお坊さんが托鉢してると
はい どうぞと それで食べて生活する
そうすると そのお坊さんが誰にも迷惑をかけないで
自然法則を守って自然破壊しないで食べたことになる
その時も念じて食べているんです
しかし 残された食べ物があってもくださいと言ってはならないんです
托鉢の場合は 人がたくさんのご飯があって
食べてたくさん残ってますね
あんた この食べ物どうしますか？と
まあ食っちゃったんだけど
捨てますよと あ 捨てるならばくださいはダメです
そこまででも言ってはダメなんです
相手がまあ捨てるんだけど
まああなた食べるならばどうぞと言ったら
まあどうぞなんです 生の穀物
命のある野菜 生野菜 生肉などは断るのです
はい じゃあここら辺は托鉢習慣だから
まあ早く行きます で 托鉢ではこの
生のものはいただけませんね
料理したものはいただくんです
自分の意思で来るならば
まあまあ それ托鉢習慣はいいんです
それは飛ばします そこは汚れ汚れもの
宗教ではね あの食べるものによって人が汚れると思っていたんですけど
お釈迦様は大反対なんですね
スッティニパータナチューラワッガーマガンダスッタというところがありまして
それできれば読んでみてほしいんですよ
日本訳もあります 過去ブッダであるカッサヤブッダの教えと解れたものです
教えとして で すごい難しいんです
一応英訳だけ一行だけ紹介します
テイキングライフビーティング
ウンディング バインディング
スティーリング ラインディセービング
ウェーレス ノッセ ノレッジ
アダルタリー ディスイス strange ノットザイーティングオブミート
いわゆる殺生すること
人を殴ること 人を縛っておくこと
人に怪我させること 盗むこと
嘘を言うこと 騙すこと
無意味な知識 それから邪な行為
これが臭いんだよと 肉じゃないんだよと
肉魚食べたっても汚れ物ではありませんと
次の偈は・・・Those who attack these living beings either out o
f greed or hostility,
and are always bent upon evil, go to darkness after death and fall headlong
into the woeful states. This is stench.
日本語訳すれば あの生命を攻撃する
もう欲で あるいは怒りで
憎しみで生命を攻撃する連中
いつでも悪いことをやっている人
苦しみ 暗闇から暗闇に行く人
もうなんか転がったように地獄に落ち
陥る生活する人 そのことが臭いんだよと
食べる肉ではありませんと
すごい明確に言っているんです
心が汚れて煩悩に支配されているならば
その生き方が汚れたものです
何の何を食べているのかではありません
たとえ落ち葉 落ちた果物だけ食しても
心が貪瞋痴で汚れているならば
その人の生き方が汚れているのです
省略する そんな意味です
摂取する食べ物と修行は関係ありません
食べるポリシーもありますね
食べるために生きることは悪です
何もしなくても必ず死ぬから
命をつなぐために食べる
自分が生きることでたくさん生命が助かっているならば
体力を維持するために解脱することは生きる目的にとして設定するならば
目的に達するまで食べる権利が生じる
これが方針なんです ありますかね
愚か者は食べるものに夢中になる
肉体が激しく要求するならば
何を食べれば良い 何か何かを食べれば良い
決して毒になりません
健康 栄養バランス 消費カロリーなどはそれほど気にする必要もありません
人格向上を目的にして生きる
体がサポートになる機械です
人格向上します 体がサポートします
体と食事の関係は 車のための旅ではなく
旅のための車という例えです
車のために旅するんじゃないんです
旅のために車を使うんです
人格向上するために食べるんです
以上です どうもありがとうございます
スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございました
本日は会場の借りている時間の都合で質疑応答は割愛させていただきます
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
拝聴してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨ イワンチャントー サンバローブー ウィナッサトゥマーテー バワントアンタラーヨ サティーディーガ
ー イコーバワ バワトゥ サッバマンガラン ラッカントゥ サンバデーヴァタ サンバブッダ アヌバーヴェーナ サンバダンマ
アヌバーヴェーナ サンバサンガ アヌバーヴェーナ サダ スッティ バワントゥ テ アビワダナ シーリスー ニッチャンワッダーパジャ
イノー チャッタールー ダンマーワッドンティー アユワンノー スカンバラン
ソーソー ありがとうございます